[Music]
the world is currently seeing its
largest movement of european refugees
since world war ii germany alone is
taking in more than 300 000 ukrainians
who are fleeing war and that number is
expected to rise dramatically
this is a refugee crisis of a much
larger dimension 2015 was a training
exercise
you know to be
very blunt and people are comparing the
current ukrainian refugee crisis to that
of 2015 when refugees arriving in the
country were fleeing war and terrorism
in syria afghanistan iraq and eritrea
vendors
on social media the discussion has
centered around the different reception
the two groups received and some users
say it's because of racism and
xenophobia
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
but since 2015 germany has also made the
integration process for new arrivals
easier let's take a look at what germany
has learned from the past what still
needs improving and what other countries
can draw from this
one lesson germany learned from the
previous effigy crisis is to integrate
newcomers as quickly as possible that
goes for both culture and language i
think the speed
of the reaction
this time
is impressive the networks in civil
society that have been mobilized
reflected there was a lot of
institutions that learned since 2015
germany's federal agency for migration
has become one of the largest asylum
agencies in the world initially bumps
got a lot of criticism for not
processing applications fast enough and
for not offering enough language and
integration classes but after hiring
more people digitizing procedures and
modernizing it systems there are now a
lot more integration classes for new
arrivals available and that's especially
important given the demographics of
ukrainians who are fleeing to germany
right now so this is a refugee movement
of
largely
mothers and their children
everybody knows that issues of schooling
education are absolutely central from
day one the good news is that schools
have also learned from their experiences
in 2015. back then they were still
working on ways how to teach and
integrate child refugees who couldn't
speak a single word of german and on
such a large scale
so they started so-called welcoming
classes or welcome classes here children
who had just arrived in the country
would initially be given german lessons
and taught how the education system
works then they were integrated into
regular classes with other german
children their own age
several schools in berlin are already
offering welcome classes for ukrainian
children like here in berlin's wedding
district
i really like this school because
the system of education in ukraine and
germany are completely different
we like talk more
so
usually when we are in ukraine we like
read and
write
very much now the city of berlin wants
to establish 250 welcome classes which
would accommodate over 2 700 ukrainian
children but what about children who
came to germany from other parts of the
world
[Music]
b
[Music]
another vital lesson learned from 2015
was the importance of finding adequate
housing for asylum seekers which was a
massive task when the refugee crisis hit
germany back then
many new arrivals were placed in crammed
asylum centers and some had to live like
that for years
foreign
well a group of berliners wanted to
change that by providing them with a
safe space a private room and a chance
to meet locals
so they founded an ngo that finds rooms
for refugees and shared apartments
across the country
from restaurants
fled from syria to germany in 2015.
after living in mass accommodation and
then in an apartment with other refugees
organized by the state he finally
managed to get a room in an apartment
with local berliners
that was all thanks to zam liam wilcome
which means living together welcome
he says the experience completely
changed the way he integrated into
society
foreign
[Music]
support is crucial
the goal of policy in germany and in
europe should be to avoid mass
accommodation but the concept doesn't
work for everyone and the structures
aren't yet in place to make this happen
on a large scale as a small-scale ngo
suzanne li and welcome have been
operating for seven years now they've
already successfully placed recently
arrived ukrainian refugees in local
apartments in fact there's even been an
increase in room offers since russia
invaded ukraine but some potential hosts
have shown a preference for hosting
refugees from ukraine over other
countries of origin
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
a big hurdle for refugees to find jobs
in germany in the past has been that
employers are often reluctant to
recognize overseas qualifications
although more than half a million asylum
seekers have managed to secure a job in
germany in recent years it hasn't been
an easy journey many say they had to
wait for years not being allowed to work
or move cities until all the
bureaucratic red tape was dealt with
while others say they have taken on jobs
that they are highly
to be able to work is crucial and this
of course was a big problem with the
previous arrivals of asylum seekers
because the silent procedures took a
long time
because some were rejected but remain
anyways and then you know spent years in
limbo not knowing what they could do
that is a very bad policy for not just
for them but for german society and
that's something politicians decided to
change this time around a week after
russia invaded ukraine the european
council agreed on an unprecedented step
ukrainian refugees were no longer
required to apply for asylum in the eu
instead they were automatically
recognized as refugees this meant that
they were given the right to work in a
country of refuge straight away a
privilege syrian afghan and iraqi
refugees didn't have when they entered
europe back then and still don't have
when they arrived today
an army of volunteers has also stepped
up to make the employment process for
ukrainians arriving now even smoother
one of them is marcus diekmann who
founded a job portal for ukrainian
refugees in order to connect them to
employers faster and the demand is huge
but the job portal called ukrainian job
aid also received some criticism that's
because apparently it addresses
ukrainian refugees and not all refugees
in germany and because offers like this
weren't available on the same scale in
2015.
is
and there are more signs that people are
stepping up to help refugees in need one
quarter of germans already actively
volunteered back in 2015 most of them
and associations and initiatives that
exist until today now estimates show the
number
is
you know i remember 2015 huge
mobilization in germany for many many
months and in the case of many for many
years to help syrian refugees afghans
gambians the difference is
that this is a conflict next to europe
and so the media attention is much
bigger
um everyone knows what's happening in
mariupol and in kharkiv and in here
secondly the people who are coming can
only come to the european union there is
no country in between
this is
some advocates hope that the enthusiasm
germans have shown in recent weeks for
helping ukrainian refugees will continue
and that it will translate to all
refugees no matter where they come from
their religion race gender or age let's
not forget we only have this war for
seven weeks
after seven weeks in 215
those who are skeptical were not very
loud because the real test will be in
four months when there might be two and
a half million refugees in germany a
number that we've never seen before uh
when we have a shortage of every you
know of kindergarten of schools then the
test will be
if uh german society will be it will
show the same empathy as now and i hope
it will and i think we should focus on
sustaining this
because there hasn't been
a refugee crisis like this in europe
since the 1940s
you